what was your first tattoo my first
tattoo is still on my back inside and
finish I'm hoping my backpiece soon but
I gotta cross with a ribbon tied around
it
oh yeah sounds my first one that's a
solid first one Yeah right like what was
your first one covered up nice 80s yeah
Bob had that Bob had Bob Filner's or
Tammany's yeah what about you I got
across my thigh okay that was our first
time yeah absolutely god can judge me
yeah he wasn't he was in the chair like
this him go first he's like this shit's
about to hurt you know I mean I'm
holding on to the chair broke out in
hives my first time really
yeah cover and I never had highs in my
life I know what was wrong my back to
nerves came I don't know like now I did
get tattooed my glands swell up my body
like every time every time did I get
tattooed even no matter where I at my
body my glands in my like you know hips
my armpits swell up it's crazy really my
nerves down of my nervous system can't
handle it interesting
that's a nice man Mike you probably had
the most famous tattoo though for sure
most recognizable tattoo in the world
have to do well it's part of your
persona now yeah it's just who you are
man
you know yeah I don't think people
really realize it either my first dad is
this dreamcatcher nice gonna when I was
18 it was number one for me feel like
Evans arms of our back piece so you can
put so much on there yeah sound like
that I want to get some more I wanna get
this arm sleeved up I got to finish this
a little bit the shaman needs a little
shading
it's conjuring the White Buffalo we got
to get tattooed on the podcast man yeah
while we're doing it we gotta get Teddy
call your guy yeah
yeah yeah dude at all want you one-stop
shop here at the Tyson ranch you got the
podcast at ad shop you got the
barbershop little workout workouts
push-up stations out back oh yeah what
about some hand tats head I might be
down for some hands yeah yeah oh yeah
this fella
that's a tough spot my stomach was my
worst by far really
why was your face the worst stomach -
yeah - no it was the worst man I was
like she knows that was the worst one
[Music]